[Music]
recently a muslim spokesman in tunisia
named saeed ketcharam who is affiliated
with the international pro-sharia
pro-caliphate organization hizbut tahrir
declared
to delighted screams of allahu akbar
from his audience that an establishment
of the
islamic state requires the conquest
of america britain russia france
and italy rome and other infidel lands
will be conquered allah willing
according to the middle east media
research institute
memory kacharam also said after the laws
of allah were abandoned
and the heretical regimes were imposed
on the muslims
the most important thing to do is to
restore the rule of the muslims
through the quran and the sunnah in
order to renew islamic life
and to deliver the islamic message to
the world my brothers
the implication of this today should be
the establishment of an islamic state
over all the lands of the muslims
and of course no call to restore the
caliphate would be complete without a
swipe at the jews
whom the quran designates at 582 the
worst enemies of the muslims
kicharam predicted that this will happen
of course after the elimination of the
filthy jewish entity
and after liberation of the lands under
direct colonization
like kashmir and others if saeed
kacharam were a non-muslim saying that
muslims needed to destroy the
filthy jewish entity and conquer america
britain russia france and italy he would
be accused of
islamophobia and bigotry but no one will
take any particular notice
of this they should however kicharam is
not some deluded fanatic raving on a
tunisian street corner
he was speaking at his but tahrir's
international caliphate conference
although his but tahrir is banned in
many countries it still has an
international presence
and recently held a conference in
chicago
nor is the desire to establish a global
caliphate limited to hizbut tahrir alone
the word khalifa means successor the
caliph in sunni islamic theology
is the successor of muhammad as the
military political
and spiritual leader of the muslims as i
show in my book the history of jihad
from muhammad to isis the great
caliphates of history
from the immediate post-muhammad period
of the rightly guided caliphs to the
umayyads abbasids and ottomans as well
as other islamic states
all waged relentless jihad warfare
against non-muslims
subjugating them under the rule of
islamic law and denying them basic
rights
these weren't the actions of a tiny
minority of extremists
abhorred by the vast majority of
peaceful muslims for
hijacking their religion this was for 14
centuries
mainstream normative islam carried forth
by the primary authorities in the
islamic world at the time
the history of jihad shows from the
accounts of eyewitnesses and
contemporary chroniclers through the
ages
that in every age and in every place
where there were muslims
some of them believed that they had a
responsibility given to them by allah
to wage war against and subjugate
unbelievers
under the rule of islamic law and so it
is today
saeed kicharam has enunciated that
responsibility more clearly indirectly
than most muslim spokesmen do these days
but he is by no means the only one who
believes that it exists
what is noteworthy also about the
history of jihad is something that it
does not contain
as the jihadis move against non-muslim
states
without any let up pause period of
coexistence
period of tolerance reformation or
reconsideration
there never appears any force of muslims
to oppose them
while it is undoubtedly true that not
all muslims in any given age have ever
waged jihad
there has never been an islamic history
an islamic entity
or organization that was opposed to
waging jihad
and dedicated to stopping those who were
waging it
so it is today islamic groups in the
west issue pro-forma condemnations after
every jihad terror attack
but are doing little or nothing to try
to prevent the next one
there is still no mosque or islamic
school in the united states
that teaches young muslims why they
should reject the understanding of islam
taught by al-qaeda
isis and other jihad terror groups
meanwhile saeed kacharam and other
islamic spokesmen openly call
for muslims to engage in jihad conquest
western authorities should be pondering
his words
and their implications very carefully
instead if they have taken any notice of
him at all which is unlikely
they have dismissed him as an extremist
they have yet to come to grips with the
fact that extremism is
and always has been so distressingly
widespread in muslim communities
but they will i'm robert spencer shulman
fellow for the david horowitz freedom
center and director of jihad watch
this video has been brought to you by
the center for security policy